alors voyez il ya des gens qui dorment
c'est le théâtre uc qui est là et là on
va rentrer dans le foyer c'est là où j
c'est là où il ya les âges et il ya le
petit déj en ce moment et c'est là où on
mange aussi faim c'est là où toute la
vie collective de l'occupation se passe
une vie collective qui dure depuis le 4
mars dernier date à laquelle
l'occupation du théâtre par ces artistes
à des maris de jour comme de nuit 42
personnes occupent en permanence
l'établissement malgré la perspective
d'une reprise d'activité le 19 mai
prochain tous ici dénonce la précarité
dans laquelle le monde de la culture est
plongé depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
ils demandent notamment le retrait de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
on n'a pas du tout été entendu sur nos
revendications ici on parle de précarité
depuis qu'on est arrivé
l'enjeu c'est de reprendre en sécurisant
les gens c'est de reprendre faisant
l'emploi avec une vraie relance pour que
une activité en 2022 reviennent à la
normale comme en 2019 s'est aussi bas
que pour tous les intermittents de
l'emploi pour tous les gens qui conduit
travail discontinue comme les nôtres ne
tombe pas au rsa ou il y en a déjà
qu'ils sont sains et soit indemnisée
on appelle ça une reprise mais pour nous
c'est pas une reprise il va voir quoi
10% 20% des artistes qui vont travailler
là va partir du 19 mai devient un
accompagnement à faire à partir de là
jusqu'à la reprise totale
pas question donc pour le moment de
stopper l'occupation pour eux elle est
parfaitement compatible avec l'accueil
du public
simon
on reconnaît qu'on est chez nous là au
théâtre de l'odéon et qu'on est tout à
fait prêt à cohabiter avec le public un
grand plaisir à accueillir le public
alors faire part de nos revendications
et sensibiliser sur nos revendications
c'est ça qu'on va essayer de faire dans
les prochains jours des délais
réouverture mais on espère qu'elle aura
lieu le 19 mai de son côté la direction
craint que la poursuite de cette action
ne perturbe la bonne reprise de
l'activité
des négociations ont été entamées entre
les deux parties le directeur du théâtre
propose ainsi une occupation de
seulement d'urnes ce qui est
incompatible
c'est la coprésence des occupants et du
public pour des raisons sanitaires
évidente
nous souhaitons arriver à un accord sur
le feu en leur proposant une occupation
durme c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent
maintenir leur occupation au foyer
laisser leurs affaires laisser leurs
banderoles
mais au moment où le public arrive ou un
peu avant qu'on ait le temps de
désinfecter on est le tendeur
d'accueillir le public dans des
conditions sanitaires irréprochable là
ils doivent quitter les lieux à ne pas
dire qu'ils peuvent pas communiquer avec
le public
tractée ce qui met le les 40 ne peuvent
pas être là reste à savoir ce que
décideront les occupants du théâtre du
côté de l'exécutif
le gouvernement a annoncé une
prolongation des indemnisations chômage
des intermittents du spectacle avec une
année blanche valable jusqu'en décembre
prochain